y la presión parcial es la presión
ejercida por un cierto gas cuando
tenemos una mezcla de gases entonces es
la presión de un gas
en una mezcla
y cuando hablamos de gases vamos a
suponer que se comportan como gases
ideales lo importante a recordar sobre
los gases ideales para esto en
particular es que las moléculas gaseosas
las moléculas gaseosas
se comportan independientemente
eso significa que no les importa la
mezcla de gases por ejemplo si fuéramos
una molécula de gas en una mezcla no nos
importaría lo que están haciendo las
otras moléculas gaseosas simplemente
hacemos lo nuestro vamos a dibujar una
imagen de esto supongamos que aquí
tenemos un contenedor que tiene
nitrógeno gaseoso lo dibujaré de color
morado entonces aquí tenemos algunas
moléculas de nitrógeno gaseoso n 2 estas
moléculas gaseosas se están moviendo
aquí se están moviendo por todo el
contenedor con una cierta velocidad y
voy a poner la dirección en la que se
mueven las moléculas gaseosas con estas
flechas entonces están moviéndose y
chocando con las paredes del contenedor
pero miren cuando chocan contra las
paredes del contenedor generan presión
entonces vamos a suponer que para este
ejemplo en particular la presión de los
gases en el contenedor este
dos atmósferas y bueno cada una de esas
moléculas gaseosas está por su lado no
están interactuando con otras moléculas
pero ahora agreguemos otro gas entonces
al mismo contenedor ahora le vamos a
agregar oxígeno gaseoso vamos a ver
nuestro contenedor tiene el mismo
volumen y no hemos cambiado la
temperatura tampoco ocurre alguna
reacción así que aún tenemos las
moléculas de n 2 que están flotando por
ahí con la misma velocidad promedio
porque la temperatura no cambio lo que
sí cambio es que ahora tenemos más
moléculas gaseosas las pondré de color
verde
ahora también tenemos estas moléculas
gaseosas que son las moléculas de otros
y también se mueven con una cierta
velocidad entonces ahora tenemos más
moléculas gaseosas de las que teníamos
originalmente y como resultado la
presión aumenta entonces la presión que
ejerce en estos gases en el contenedor
la voy a llamar presión total la presión
total es de 2.5 atmósferas y tal vez nos
preguntemos cuál es la presión parcial
del nitrógeno o cuál es la presión
parcial del oxígeno lo escribimos así
ponemos como subíndice lo que sea que
estamos buscando ahora al principio
dijimos que las moléculas gaseosas se
comportan independientemente y cómo se
comportan independientemente entonces
simplemente podemos sumar las presiones
parciales de la mezcla para obtener la
presión total entonces una ecuación que
veremos para la presión parcial es la
presión total es igual a la sumatoria de
las presiones parciales
todos los gases que tengamos en la
mezcla todos los gases punto punto punto
a esta ecuación se le conoce como la ley
de dalton o ley de las expresiones
parciales dalton
entonces esta es una forma en la que
podemos conocer las presiones parciales
y si conocemos la presión total y
conocemos las presiones parciales de los
otros gases en nuestra mezcla podremos
conocer la presión parcial que estemos
buscando y eso es lo que vamos a hacer
entonces para este sistema en particular
podemos decir que la presión total que
ya sabemos que es igual a 2.5 esa
presión total debe ser igual a la
presión parcial del nitrógeno más la
presión parcial del oxígeno y miren
también conocemos la presión parcial del
nitrógeno porque la presión parcial del
nitrógeno es de 2 atmósferas y eso no
cambia aquí porque la presión parcial
del nitrógeno sigue siendo de 2 puntos 0
atmósferas aún después de agregar
oxígeno gaseoso y eso es porque la ley
de los gases ideales dice que pp es
igual a n rt
y reescribimos esto en términos de la
presión nos queda que p es igual a n r t
entre el volumen entonces si el
nitrógeno gaseoso se comporta como un
gas ideal su presión solamente cambiaría
si modificamos el número de moles la
temperatura o el volumen pero como no
hemos modificado nada de eso y solamente
agregamos otro gas y no cambia el número
de moléculas la temperatura o el volumen
la presión parcial o dicho de otra
manera la presión ejercida por las
moléculas de nitrógeno gaseoso sigue
siendo de todos atmósferas entonces ya
sabemos que la presión total es de 2.5
atmósferas
y la presión parcial de nitrógeno como
ya dijimos es de dos atmósferas y
queremos saber la presión parcial del
oxígeno
ahora solo tenemos que reordenar esta
ecuación para calcular p o 2 entonces
veo 2 es igual a la presión total que es
de 2.5 atmósferas menos la presión
parcial del nitrógeno así nos queda que
la presión parcial del oxígeno es de 0.5
atmósferas así que ya sabemos cómo usar
la ley de dalton o ley de las presiones
parciales para encontrar una presión
parcial claro si conocemos la presión
total y las otras presiones parciales